[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
me
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
me
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
me
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
what's going on you guys gaming guy here
uh coming at you with another attic show
we got hero hustle uh what's going on
hustle
not much man that much i am gearing up
to start the artful escape later on like
pretty much right after we finished um i
finally jumped back on game pass i feel
like i had to plus they offered it four
dollars so i had to jump back on it and
um
i saw demi god um shout out to demi god
over there level one like he actually
reviewed it i know this game isn't that
long but i always enjoyed the art style
of it
what's going on with you kane sir
uh
unfortunately um i'm not allowed to talk
about what i'm playing and what's what's
crazy is like
the way that in
ndas and stuff work like it says
please don't tell people that that
you're reviewing the game that we're
talking about
but i noticed yesterday xbox
revealed what you like you know how like
xbox will tell you what you're playing
they just stitching on what i'm playing
so like my thought process is like if i
can't tell anybody
maybe
your actual thing shouldn't tell me
so it was it was interesting man it was
interesting but uh you know
more on that here later you guys i think
you guys will uh well i'm pretty sure
that you could take a wild guess what
i'm reviewing but i can't actually tell
you guys i'm reviewing it but uh you
know yeah i just put two and two
together hey addict they said i'm a
little bit low in the chat how about now
i turn myself up a little bit but if you
could turn me up that'd be better yeah i
turned you up now um
hopefully
hopefully it's good now
i can't turn them i don't have the
ability to turn my no i don't no i can't
turn myself up i guess all right how
does he sound now guys how does he sound
now y'all let me know y'all let me know
yo i like the transition we got like the
little the little yeah yeah yeah yeah
yeah it took me a little bit but i got
it i got stuff going man we improving
slowly but surely we implore them
all right so yeah
i think the first thing we're going to
talk about
is state of play um i know
we missed that last week i think it was
thursday last week what so we did miss
that
so i want to briefly go over say the
play i don't think there's a whole lot
to talk about when it comes to state of
play but i do want to briefly go over it
because i feel like it was that bad so
you know for those of you that don't
know on this channel actually you can go
and watch uh
our reaction because hustle was in there
with me and king it was me king and
hustle uh we reacted to the state of
play that we're about to refer to
and uh you know what
what thing i want to know hustle is uh
how did you feel about that state of
play
okay so
as you know me right and as the chat
gets to know me y'all know
i'm mr positive super positive and i try
not to be disingenuous with my
positivity but uh
that show was pretty bad now
i said it during the reaction last week
that hey i'm not on it i'm not on
twitter as much as i used to be just
because of my job and certain things
have changed
so i was wondering if playstation is
sent out like the quick like disclaimer
like hey don't get too excited we're
just showing indies and third party i
wonder if they sent that out because if
they sent that out
most of it is forgiven but honestly that
show was not good the show wasn't good
little hold on the monster inside
was good
uh king put me on like star oh she know
whatever that was and i said i would say
that that's okay based off of his
recommendation i want to go check that
out and i saw a couple i saw king of
fighters which was you know i love
fighting games like that was cool but
it was it was one of the game that kind
of escapes me but not really though that
that wasn't the one that everybody
shouldn't have been streaming
in my opinion
yeah it i think the biggest issue that
the shows
held is
sure did they realistically did they try
to keep your expectations and check yes
but i don't think they did enough i i
think that they promised third party
a third-party state of play which in a
variety of things can mean a different
thing a different amount of things so i
think the issue was is how they
presented it and the expectations that
they set for with the third parties when
you say something like third parties you
think especially someone like sony that
has a lot of timed exclusives such as
the final fantasy franchise you know
maybe we would have seen something from
uh square enix could have been there
capcom you know we don't know what
they're doing behind closed doors in
terms of third party so people
automatically assume we're gonna see
final fantasy 16 there we're gonna see
you know uh maybe final fantasy remake
two which that's a stretch it's probably
not happening but it is something that
can't happen because it's a third party
and i think that was the biggest issue
is they didn't be a little bit more
specific they should have said this is
going to be an indie show and we're
going to show a lot more of the
up-and-coming titles i'm not necessarily
you know big third-party titles because
to me
this was the worst state of play in
inside xbox has ever done like inside
xbox has made some pretty bad shows
that's poorly paced and i feel like you
know there's a lot of things inside xbox
can improve on whenever they bring that
format back but this is worse than than
anything they've ever done like xbox
playstation nintendo i was bored from
the time this thing started to the time
this thing ended
and
they got they got to do better on stuff
like that they got to be a little bit
more compu
communication they got to have more of
that so how do you feel do you feel like
that maybe the communication wasn't
there
yeah again and if the communication was
there to anybody in a child who saw it
go ahead and tweet me um hustling
motivated on twitter y'all go ahead and
tweet that at me because like i said
again i didn't see it all would well
most of it will be forgiven if they was
like hey you know just quick little
don't get your hopes up type thing
i'm cool with that and um you mentioned
that earlier um the last um that last
was a final fantasy like the second part
of the i guess we're assuming it's going
to be three parts
we we saw like the dlc what was the last
year they came out they was the the
yuffie or yuffie dlc i'm not familiar
with like the final fantasy character so
you had to educate me sir
it is kind of uh we haven't heard
anything more about that it would be
great if we would have gotten that
because you did say that this was third
party um there are a lot of other third
parties that you know that are kind of
like rumored to have have happened like
i don't know if you know but you know
they're rumored to like release another
boxing game
no no no no yeah it's another boston
game that's like ruined on the horizon
like
of course i mean of course you don't
break news there but here's the best
part about that show
no no t no shade but there's only 20
minutes like we was only in we was
kicking it for a while but the show
wasn't that long
i can't be too late
hold up let me
let me bring up the show we did on uh
the other screen
that we did that
for an hour and 26 minutes
how did we like you know i'm sorry i'll
be the goat we made a 20 minute
i gotta say man
horrible show
into an hour and 26 minutes of gold uh
gold like straight up gold keep in mind
we did react also to the uh to the halo
infinite thing so if you guys want to go
back and check out that you could
definitely do that um you know
at the end of the day
i don't think this is like a bad show in
terms of what they showed i just think
that they needed to be a little bit more
transparent to what was actually going
to be there and if they would have just
came out and said yo this is going to be
indies don't expect anything in form of
like a huge third-party present it's not
going to be there uh what's funny is
they showed star ocean and then we found
out after the show it's on xbox too so
it's
it's on xbox xbox one right i know it's
a series s and x is it on the pre
previous game consoles ps4 i don't know
i didn't see that all i saw
is people tagging me
you and king over and over again
saying that this game is on xbox and
they taking a huge huge l
but we got a five dollar switch from
flame it was so short by the time we
knew
we were getting
conned they ran out the door y'all were
stuck by the smooth criminal also hi
guys what's up i appreciate the super
chat playing look you're right man i i
do feel like they needed to
apparently he said it is crosston so i
think uh you know that that's another l
it's on older generation
oh that's not a l
that's a big ass
you know what i'm gonna have some stuff
like like how do you guys feel about
this like because you obviously this
isn't as scripted as like an iop but i
want to make because i'm doing more
reviews i want to make
you know how like
back in the old days like when they when
they would write letters they would
stamp it with an insignia
i want to have i want to make insignias
for iop in the attic show
if i don't like something i press a
button and i stamp it with like the
wrong one like and then if i like it we
call it iop approved
so you know i want to do something like
that with with uh in terms of
the
the aspect of reviews like if i like a
review and i really enjoy the game at
the very end like over the game i just
put like iop approved or something like
that or the royal stamp i don't know
obviously we uh we we could figure out
the the names and stuff afterwards but
tell me how you guys feel about that
about that in the chat man
before we move on before we move on um
is that emperor zergy shout out to you
yeah what was abandoned like because we
remember there was like a big
controversy with abandoned in general
and then they think it was cody landed
abandoned man yeah
that uh silence is
alleged silent hill with my camera
silent hill remake reboot remastered i
mean look man that was a lot um i said
this during the stream but i was kind of
surprised that they didn't that they
didn't show grand theft auto um the
trilogy i'm surprised they didn't show
it i'm like yo if
hey look that that could have really
saved that show i know why our people
got their feelings on it that's my
nostalgia talking i love san andreas and
vice city three is cool i haven't beat
three yet so i'm not going to speak on
it too much but it would have been dope
had they showed that because that's
getting ready to come out in a matter of
eight days or eleven what ten days what
that what's the day the second um
yes the second nah okay so nine days
from now yeah i'm gonna partake on grand
theft auto ps5 and then on ps5
yeah that's what's up you know when it
comes to
stuff like that like
it is on game pass so at least you know
uh i could play san andreas and i've
always enjoyed out of all the gta san
andreas was always the one that
resonated me the most
um
i've always enjoyed that game i i
thought it was well paced i thought the
way that the story was well done to be
honest with you i felt like
that story
i think the quality of five is better
than san andreas but i think the story
is better in san andreas than five
uh
you know you you you get kicked out it
goes to another because it felt like
there was a purpose in everything doing
it felt like like you know uh cj
didn't have control over his life it was
just like he always had to like run from
but on this one
they kind of try to split that with
three different characters and i think
that they all did okay things but none
of them did individually what cj did in
san andreas
yeah and i think i think the reason why
you feel that way um is because it's
centered around the one
excuse me centered around the one
character
cj as you well i'm not gonna spoil it so
for those who all haven't played it but
you know what happens to cj while he was
up in liberty city while he comes back
you know what happens to him as soon as
he comes back he gets you know he gets
to running around and then he's you know
and then they ship him out to the
country like it's there's a lot to like
take in with that um i'm looking forward
to running through that one again um
it's my favorite one but i do love i
love the music in vice city and um for
the record for the racket where's where
is wait is it
oh what's he doing over here i had to do
it i had to do it uh vice city and part
three i got san andreas in the drawers
somewhere i got it in here somewhere
just just know i got it anyway um i had
to do it because i want and i know we
talk about the playstation thing but i
want to see if they're going to change
some of the music on
from the old version to the new version
because you know licenses they do run
out at a certain point
um
michael jackson has been accused of
certain things
in his death and even when he was alive
so what i'm wondering it might be up out
of there i like that there's a chance on
that
yep
yep i definitely you know hate to like
divert a little bit uh we seem to do
that a lot on this show but absolutely
like look i'm not a fan like i i see a
lot of censoring going on like look
regardless what happened in the past
with this and that i'm not a fan of
altering something about a game that
could be put back in the game you know
what i'm saying like you know
i i see it a lot when it comes to like
doing world war ii stuff when it comes
to like uh certain symbols uh with the
nazi stuff like i get it that is a
horrible time in the cut in in history
but if you're going to do a game in that
section of the world in that section in
that time frame you can't really just
remove that because that removes it from
history and as much as i would love for
it to be out of history like poff gone
though life doesn't work that way you
know what i'm saying like
i'm gonna give you a little pushback on
that now when you made the example that
you just made that has to be there for
historic purposes like i get stuff like
that because that's that part of the
world like wolfenstein like that type of
industry imagery imagery
english hustle good lord do you speak it
that type of imagery has to be there
grand theft auto um you are referring to
the removal of the confederate flag it
actually played no part in no no i'm not
talking about the thing about the music
i was talking about the music
and gca wait did you so did you see the
other thing because they they removed
that as well they didn't remove the
confederate flag from um
that
like something like that i do think
that's like on the border line that's
like oh you know okay because that
that's what that character was that was
his origins so it's like you could take
that out and it doesn't really affect
the story so that's okay but if you if
they're if we're willing to let them
take that out what's you know what what
are we going to draw the line you know
and i think it's very important to draw
those lines before those lines are taken
advantage of
and you know i don't to be honest with
you i don't care if they take the nazi
flag out of everything the confederate
flag out of everything but there is to a
point where this history
is there for a reason to
know that that happened and it can't
happen again and if you just remove it
then clearly you know people ain't going
to be taught it and you know we don't
want to go too much into a giant spiral
but you know
did you see okay man we keep going i was
a little tired but now a little bit more
awake did you see the thing sony was
censoring
um i saw
who was it someone player essence he
made a video shout out to player essence
go watch that video apparently there is
a game okay it's a little bit crazy game
okay i'll get it like it's a little bit
of a perverted game that's on like the
switch and playstation so oh okay
playstation remove the uh you know the
the revealing closed chicks that's in it
well you know this game should never
have came out it let's be real this game
is crazy should never have came out but
if you look
at what sony did they let the game come
out but they made them redraw the women
as like foxes like animals instead of
women like and i just
i just like look man
this game's kind of sleazy and i don't
think it should exist
but how you just gonna have them rewrite
their art you know what i'm saying just
tell them it's not coming on your
platform
you gotta see that after the podcast but
you gotta go watch that it is it is
crazy
i can understand where sony's coming
from with them being on their side
because i don't think the game should
have came out sony was probably like
look
we do want to support you but we don't
want this on our platform and they gave
them that ultimatum so you know they
probably made money at being on the
playstation in general so i understand
where it's coming from on playstation
side where uh you know we can't say for
them to support uh developers and then
tell them yo we're not putting your
stuff on and at least not try to work
with them so they did work with them in
some form
but to completely rewrite the stuff man
like
eric you know i can't roll with that
you know i love naughty dog
you know how gruesome the last of us two
is like it seems like you brought that
up
you brought that up he was talking about
the sex scene with abby and he's like so
you needed to tell me because i i they
were clothed to my knowledge i don't
know obviously he he censored stuff i
don't know if it was censored for his
video or it was censored in general but
i highly doubt the switch is gonna put
uh you know people uh
completely naked in their stuff so and
what was interesting is like
it's okay for the abbey scene to be in
last of us
but this this indie developer you got to
get that up out of here we don't need
that it's yeah my only issue is not it's
not the censorship itself it's like if
you go on censor something all right if
you're gonna go somewhere with it go all
the way with it don't just exclude your
people just because you feel like it's
type of artistic stance because it could
be right the brutality in the last of us
or just whatever whatever i say the last
of us it could be any other game right
if this game is how this game is and if
you want to censor that cool go ahead
and censor that but just make sure you
get everybody don't just pick and choose
because that's what it seems like sony
is doing um i think i must have heard it
on weapon wheel they was they're kind of
picking and choosing and they're making
things different um i think jack had
brought up god of war how you don't
really kill like the human looking
enemies in a gruesome fashion but you'll
kill like the like the little wolves or
like the
the non-human enemies and i got three
and a half hours in that game you're
right i can rip a head off the joint and
feel like a boss but like when they come
to like the humans you don't really you
don't get it on like that and to be
honest with you
god of war
that was kind of it that that was his
motive he was a very gruesome
very gory and he didn't really give
anyone mercy like i remember like
remember he fought the
hermeties or the one that's really fast
with the wings he rips his wings off
you said you mean in the old god of wars
right yeah the old god okay so thank you
i i definitely see a little bit of
censorship and i do sympathize with a
lot of people in terms of how they are
censoring [ __ ] um
i do see it but at the end of the day i
don't think they've done anything that
makes me feel like it shouldn't have
been censored yet you know what i'm
saying i do agree with you in terms of
making it more consistent we can't let
you we can't do it but then we tell
other people they can't do it i
understand that and i think that is a
little bit ridiculous but in terms of
them censoring stuff they haven't
censored something that i'm just like
that shouldn't happen now i'm sure
there's stuff out there because i don't
keep up with the centering uh field i
really don't care what sensor or what's
not censored um i do have a point when
it comes to historical censoring but
even that i don't care it's just i do
understand people's thought process in
terms of that but we're gonna go and
move on off of that because we're just
gonna keep going in a giant spiral
you know
but there's not really much to say about
state of play was it was trash that they
they they need to be more
communication with us and them
uh which something they don't really do
we can all agree that sony needs to have
more communication in general they don't
really have communication i i feel like
for the most part when it comes to sony
communication it's we're gonna do
something this day be there that's all
there's no in-between there's no you
know i feel like now when microsoft does
something bad when aaron greenberg comes
out there makes a promise that wasn't
realistically kept aaron grieber comes
out and says i was wrong i shouldn't
have done that and i don't feel like we
get enough of that from sony you know
when when they came out and they said
that we're going to do better on that we
should have
worded it different it wasn't gameplay
we need to do better i see that as them
taking responsibility and then taking
ownership and they're going to improve
on that but then when sony just stays
quiet for a whole day after having a
horrible state of play is are they in
the wrong no but i do feel like there
was a huge gray area where they could
have done better and i do feel like sony
in terms of pr movement they they'd
rather keep quiet than actually address
the issue
so let's talk about digital foundry
i i'm sure you saw i sent you the video
this morning uh yeah so did you for
those of you that know digital foundry
did a podcast and at the beginning of
the podcast they talked about
halo infinite
uh there was three individuals on there
one was the main dude from digital
foundry and then two of like the writers
i don't know i don't richard okay so
richard live better alex battaglia i'm
up messed his name up
and tom whose last name i can't quite
pronounce either who hasn't been there
in quite some time they they had some
pretty uh
what attic would you say that these
things were
truthful or would you say that these
things were harsh things about the uh
halo infinite six-minute trailer that
they just showed for the campaign
i think
they have the right to their opinion
i think that the stuff they said
is concerning um
you know uh he brought up that he
personally felt like halo 4 looks better
than halo infinite i'd agree
uh i do think halo infinite uh halo 4
looks better than halo infinite uh
because halo 4 in my personal opinion
looks good to this day
like that game is gorgeous to this day
sometimes when i make halo videos i get
scenes from halo 4 because that's how
good it looks in a video so i can
understand that kind of logic and
understand that kind of thought process
but halo 4 and halo infinite are two
entirely different games one's open
world a lot more freedom and world is a
very corridor shooter
so i can understand that thought process
i don't agree because i don't feel like
halo if it looks horrible or we have to
compare it to halo 4 but i do understand
where he's coming from on that uh but
that's all i understand where he's
coming from um i felt like they're being
too hard on this he was acting like
there was no improvement whatsoever and
i think that's just a
i don't that's a lot i don't know what
we was looking at like that that's a lie
that's that come on because you can't
you can't look at the
the
atmosphere first let's start with the
atmosphere if you follow the 343 blog
like i do you know you saw the changes
that they made now
oh indeed indeed now if you don't like
the new changes cool you cannot like
them but you can't say that they are an
improvement over the ones that we saw at
the
whatever 2019 whatever that was you
can't say that that was the thing
now you can argue that some character
models they improve but they only
improve like
that months really they didn't really
because i'm referring to craig
but honestly man i'm like it looks a
little bit better not too much better
just a little bit better but
oh man i don't know um one of the
gentlemen i can't remember who exactly
who it was he said he doesn't like what
halo is turning into um ladies and
gentlemen halo came out in 2001.
november 15 2001 to be exact this game
will be over 20 years old man like
if this game didn't
try to move the needle forward or didn't
try to do something different or didn't
try to do something innovative oh you
know what what what cogs say burgers
fries and shake it'd be the same old
same old then they'd be complaining
about that man so we got to see how the
game plays in terms of the rpg elements
before we can make that determination i
don't think that that's
right graphically all right you can have
whatever gripe you want to have about
that but i don't think that like we can
we can't talk about the game plan until
we actually play the game and i'm gonna
be real with you i actually jump back on
game pass just because of that six
minutes that i saw i like the different
little things that i saw like the
different little elements that i saw i
like the fact that it is kind of turning
this one off pg the fact that you gotta
like
pick your abilities and you can play the
game kind of how you want i don't like
the open world thing so much but i'm
just not you know i only play open world
stuff like grand theft auto like i hate
for the record i love uncharted i love
uncharted lost legacy i hate the fact
that when you hit chapter four they make
you go all around i hate to not just
keep me in one direction like i'm cool
with that you don't gotta do all that
and i i'm i feel like i'm gonna feel the
same way with halo but i'll make that
determination when it's time
there was a lot of uh a lot of
nitpicking um i almost called you alex
it was a lot of nitpicking no addict it
was it was kind of i don't wanna i don't
to say fanboys because we know how
digital foundry get down like and they
they got we're gonna put respect on
their name but that one was kind of i
don't somehow some of it not all of it
some other was kind of little unfair in
my opinion
and i don't like the way it was
delivered like
it's one thing to say that you disagree
with how they're doing things it's one
thing to say that you don't think that
there's a whole lot of improvements but
they didn't say one positive thing about
halo i i find it hard to believe if you
enjoy halo
that you didn't find anything that
you're liking about a little infinite
like to me
i'm watching this and we got friends
over there digital foundry but i always
got to keep it a hundred
it really felt like they weren't they
they were looking for reasons to like uh
to hate this game and it felt like they
just wanted clicks i'm gonna be real
with you because
first off it's at the beginning of the
podcast
first thing they're talking about i'm
not saying this is generally not how
these people feel but i'm saying that
they were going hardcore
and to me if you're a halo fan and
you've enjoyed halo this is one of the
first installments that you feel a
little bit more comfortable because it
looks like more of the old halos it
feels like more of the old halos but to
me if you come out at the gate
and say this doesn't look right that
doesn't look right i'm not feeling the
way halos
i'm starting to judge
did you even play the old halos how much
of the old halos did you play did you
play only four and five like i don't
understand how you watch all of infinite
and you can't find one positive thing
that you really enjoy what's going on to
me
it was a witch hunt they was looking for
anything they could to you know speak
negatively about the game and i don't
like saying stuff like that but
i it just it didn't it i just i wasn't
feeling the vibe i didn't see the
passion in their voice
well obviously i can't see a voice but i
didn't feel the passion in their voice i
didn't i didn't feel like they was even
enjoying what they were speaking it felt
like it was just something on the screen
that they had to talk about and it
wasn't actually something they wanted to
talk about like i don't know how much
they play games i don't i don't keep
track of digital foundry i don't keep
track of anything digital foundry really
i don't even watch their breakdowns i
don't care like i really don't
but when i watched this because people
were sharing
the halo 4 thing so i went back uh
before the podcast i'm like let me watch
the whole show not the whole show i i
don't watch the podcast but let me watch
the beginning of it and see what they're
talking about halo
i just didn't feel passion coming out of
it like
they weren't really giving it like
chris ray gun you know over there at
last stand media he's on sacred symbols
when he talks about halo
you sense
the halo
energy coming off of him you feel like
he knows what he's talking about he's
not just talking about why he doesn't
like something he's giving you examples
of why he doesn't like it he's giving
you references to older halos of why he
doesn't like something it really just
felt like yeah it just didn't look good
uh i didn't like the way this looked
they didn't really explain why they
didn't like it you know
and i
i'm sorry
yeah i want to shoot alex a little bit
about alex patel because he didn't say
he did he's
he did a video or did some content with
efo's box and i hope i get his name
right um he said he would with andy over
there so he said he did some you know he
said he did some content so maybe it's
more to
you know more maybe he explains a lot
more into video but you know i feel like
and you know
um i almost called you alex again sir
hustle stop you're fine
you know it's close enough yeah yeah
well you you know for a fact that i
prefer gears over hello you know i play
i play halo reach be hello reach play
halo 1 back in the day when the first
came out be hella on me and my brother
play hello three and i kind of just
stopped playing i've been playing halo 5
the multiplayer recently and i've been
playing um and i played the uh the halo
infinite beta you know with the squad or
whatever right
i i'll tell you personally speaking like
out of those six minutes that we got for
the trailer there's a lot that you can
like really unpack from it and it's a
super dope trailer um
well and after we we get done critiquing
them i just i just want to take some
time to talk about the weapon because i
think that she's super endearing that's
explain to me how they i'm pretty sure
that was just talking about the game in
general wasn't it they just highlighted
a lot of
the the art designs and choice like i
they weren't talking about anything lore
wise they didn't talk about the the
elite that's going around killing
spartans they didn't talk about a weapon
i really i didn't really see them talk
about her too much uh if any uh they
didn't talk about the forerunner uh
wannabe or the the the charlotte and
whatever that forerunner was that threw
uh halo that threw master chief through
a couple walls like to me like how are
you only going to highlight the stuff
you don't like but you don't even talk
about the stuff that you enjoyed and
that's the issue i really have with the
stuff man uh you know we got a five
dollar subject from mark uh
yee
shout out to the homies i'm
i appreciate the uh the the love uh mark
i think that's my issue
all
love over there to digital foundry
they're just doing what they do and
that's their their that's their opinion
and they could be huge fans of halo and
that's fine but all i'm saying from a
perspective of someone that loved the
halo halo that loves the halo franchise
i just didn't feel the energy and i
didn't feel the love over there i i just
didn't you know if they have if they
feel away i definitely understand that
you know we come on here man we'll talk
about it and we'll see what's up man
because i you know they do a phenomenal
job over there that i don't i don't keep
up with
indeed
but i i do keep up with it and and i'll
tell you that they do they definitely do
a phenomenal job and you know that
they're super analytical um
side note before we move on um i love df
retro like edit as you know i may have
been back in my retro bag and everything
and like df retro like really offered
something different i know that had
nothing to do with this i just kind of
wanted to shout out the effort because i
like i like dear friends i'm not gonna
lie um
yeah i'm looking forward to the game um
i will be playing it day one maybe not
the campaign but i'm definitely that
multiplayer day one but uh i got game
pass so i'm gonna run through it i
really want to wait until the co-op
drops man i know this has nothing to do
with that but i won't wait till that
co-op drops me contouring and uh mega
mega zx456 like we just be halo reach
you know we're gonna run it back with
the new one at some point whatever that
whatever the co-op drop
we're doing good on time so we can all
divert a little bit here how did you
feel about halo reach
fun like the the story in general like
it's the best story that's been in haiti
hey and that is that's a doozy for me
but like one of my main gripes against
master chief in particular is that like
he's like triple h like
triple h is an attitude there for all my
wrestling fans you know what i mean by
that he wasn't like the man he was
always the man next to the man for
example triple h was there was stone
cold who was way higher than him he was
there but the rock was way higher than
them he was there but the undertaker who
was higher than him hell he was there
with mankind who was a little bit higher
than triple h in my humble opinion so he
wasn't quite the man but he was always
the man next to the man and what i mean
by this
master tv boring
it's like it's the other people around
master chief that made it and you know
for me you know i that's why i like
343's uh
version of master chief more because i
felt like
three three four three they make him
more human they give him more
of an emotional side
they're the ones that creepily have him
like fall in love with cortana and i
know you know the dude you know he's
been around her the dude cares about
cortana you don't want her just
disappearing uh so i like that side of
cortana i like the fact that you know
you see master chief get more emotional
when it comes to certain things you see
that that side of a min and what and i
felt like when it come to
halo one through three
he was just there he didn't really uh
you know he said the one-liners and i i
never really liked that that's always
like what what 343 has done with master
chief now obviously i wish they'd do it
better
but you know i do like the direction
that master chief's going i just wish
they would do it better like but you
know we'll have to see how infinite goes
in terms of because it does look like
you know he's getting some kind of bond
weapon
whatever her name is he's getting some
kind of bond with um
with the other guys
the pilot we'll just call him the pilot
but i do see some a chat that i want to
i want to talk about real quick because
i'm curious to hear your opinion on this
and i'm actually going to change
the title because i do want to talk
about this
do you think
okay
let's just set up let's just not go
straight into it
for those of you that know
dr disrespect is a huge streamer
uh you know i don't agree with a lot of
the things he says but he made an
interesting
statement that he feels like
halo infinite is going to
die off eventually because it doesn't
have a bad royale how do you feel about
that state
i feel like halo was probably one of
those games that doesn't need it i
understand why you would implement it
because it's a sign of the times but i'm
gonna be honest with you
to me
to me
look
the br thing is is done
i feel like the best people who did it
and now i know y'all know if y'all
agreeing that pub g was like the funnest
like that i've had with battle royale
fortnite cool whatever but like the
tense moment of just watching that
bubble on pub g just
you know get smaller get smaller get
smaller like that's just like a real
tense thing i don't think halo
particularly needs that um i did play
that multiplayer beta and i'll be real
with you like they don't
i feel like they don't got to copy
nobody else in fact
what i would love 343 to do is to
innovate come up with something they own
and i know that they can do it too i
know that they can do it
all right here's here's how i feel
okay i know i'm about to piss off the
chat but i piss you guys off every week
so it's okay man i do i do agree with dr
disrespect and i don't agree with it day
one but i do agree that they would be
dumb not to imply some kind of
battle royale into the game uh this is
how i would do it i'm just gonna be real
with you guys
i would have everyone be od
go ahead um i just saw that
chill y'all
literally five dollars super chat don't
disrespect stay five uh stay faithful to
his wife much less one game he's gonna
jump to whatever his biggest at the time
i don't pay him no mind that's so crazy
see that they have no problem super
chatting smoke that's what i love about
arc i see but you guys do need to calm
down a little bit
[Music]
this is how i would like for it to do i
would like
get a reach map you know get maps in the
game
and i would like instead of everyone
being spartans just let people be odsd
i would like
the drop pause that they do
that replaces the ship
so the map pops up at the beginning
everyone chooses where they want to go
and you just get shot down there with
the with the or uh with your little
satellite thing whatever it's called
i don't know exactly what the odsd
little drop paul it's called and like so
so imagine like it starts it pops up you
like there's like a little diagram you
put where you want to when you press x
it shoots you down to that spot
i think that would be a very unique way
of doing it maybe they can have certain
uh
certain areas on the map to where
if you go and you can able to hold that
point for a certain amount of time one
of your teammates can can have can be uh
augmentated on and become a spartan
uh so you know i think there's a lot of
different scenarios that they just think
about it guys i know
that you guys
are always against you know implying
stuff that doesn't make sense into a
franchise i will agree with you that it
doesn't need it but i'm not gonna say it
shouldn't have it
halo has always been especially the
multiplayer
about what you pick up and what you
maintain to keep the games up
so to me
out of everything that should have a
battle royale this is the game that
should have a battle royale you start
you're looking for the br you're looking
for the ar you're looking for the
equipment you're looking for the
vehicles this game is
br all over it i'm gonna be real with
you
halo
the very foundation halo is built on can
make a great vr i get it you guys don't
think it doesn't need it and it doesn't
need it but i think we can all agree
that the biggest games being told right
now have br it doesn't hurt it to have
its own version of it we got a two
dollar super chat from flame
halo already has a br that battle rifle
you got a point there man but yeah i
just that's my only thing i don't know
how you feel about the hustle we'll let
you uh you know go off of that i just
feel like if they're willing to put it
in there and they're willing to do it
right that's the key point it's got to
be done right
why what what's the issue
all right i'll say this all right if
they're not gonna implement it they want
all right cool
but
they don't need no more extra on their
plate right now let's let them get this
out the door let this joint be great
that's that's more concerned about that
you know we was in the last segment i
guess
i guess a second yeah and the last the
last topic the last segment when i spoke
about digital foundry's reaction to it
let them focus on all that other stuff
first because the gameplay in my opinion
is already there it's already fun if you
want to add that to later date cool
cause eric you know the first thing i'm
gonna do
first thing i'm gonna do is i'm gonna
find some sticker grenades and i'm gonna
get my call of duty i'm just gonna throw
them
i'm just gonna see if i can stick
somebody i've done it before like yeah
imagine what it would be like like uh
for those of you guys that don't know
like when you played the original halos
and you would like uh
extend the drawbridges remember like the
energy bridges that you have to fight to
turn on and stuff imagine maps being
made strategically to you stuff like
that like that's what i'm saying like
the bigger picture chat the bigger
picture this game needs to have a br it
doesn't have to have it it just needs it
i feel like if they build a br correctly
and they did it right they could have
the best br on the market because halo
foundation is so br
friendly and that's just my opinion on
the matter uh you know i i just i want
what's best for halo and i do feel like
sure you don't need it at launch but
after about six months two years you
know uh people getting tired of the same
you know ranked matches arena matches
big team battle matches you know drop a
br on that community drop a battle rifle
on that community drop a battle royale
on that community and tell them have fun
and what's funny
is i know some of these people in the
chat if they did it right
you guys would not be in this chat
telling me not to do it
i feel like if they're willing to do it
correctly what do we got to lose
indeed
the chat knows why we're here
sega and microsoft announced a
partnership
using the azure
servers
i don't know we ain't
[Music]
okay i will pronounce anything however i
want to
so they announce
keep in mind i said microsoft not xbox
uh sarah bond did come out in
formerly uh you know pretty much
say how much she appreciated this kind
of partnership and how she is going to
look forward to working with them in the
future so i do think there is some
gaming in this my question to you is
hustle and the question that i have for
you right now
in the attic i was about to say the
round but we ain't in the realm so and
the acting show is
do you think this is gonna be huge in
the gaming report or do you think this
is gonna be this little bit of gaming
leak but it's mainly just
for business aspects
i think i think both of these uh both of
these scenarios can be true i think this
is like something of a testing the
waters type thing um you remember back
when
bethesda had issues with uh fallout 76
todd howard came out
he said the first people that he reached
out to was xbox this is before microsoft
bill spencer that was the first person
he called us phil spencer indeed now
before you know before things happen and
i don't want to step well you know what
i'm more expecting that i'm going to
have some fun this time you know before
all of that popped off when we got the
bethesda deal that we gathered we got
the xenoblade steal that we got
they reached out first and they asked
for help now without when i read the
article that you sent me via ign shout
out to ign for this
it seems like to me that they said they
were making a global honor i want to
make sure i get it right too they said
they're make they said they want to
focus on a they want to focus on global
online communities now that to me sounds
like multiplayer i don't know what in
terms of multiplayer but i see they
haven't been they got the fantastic star
franchise so maybe it's something to do
a fantasy star
they got that i also see a picture of
star with the hedgehog um it could be
jet set radio future it could be could
be a
ton of different things radio
it could be
it could be pick my eyeballs out if it's
that damn game
can
i want persona on my platform before we
talk about getting any of your guys's
platform i only care what i want all
right but i want persona why would i
care if you guys get what you want that
game is like 50 years old let that [ __ ]
be 50 years old
i i i'm just joking if you guys want
dead set radio and they give jesse radio
i ain't going hate i'ma just be upset
because i still ain't got persona and i
think that's until they get persona they
on my [ __ ] list
hey i feel you won that but you know
that they also said that they made it
seemed like this would be like a new
experience they made it seem like it
would be a new title from what i briefly
had the opportunity to read so you know
the sky's the limit man and um i feel
like this is like
not the limit until we get persona right
now
well so right now the ceiling of my
house is the limit
but once we get to persona once we get
persona then we can go past my ceiling
but until the ceiling is meant and the
ceiling is persona we're not doing no
more after that
jet set radio this chat man i mean i
mean you know there's a lot um virtual
fighter like
because you know because it seemed like
sega in in xbox or microsoft writer
they're already like working their hand
in hand like if you want to go right now
on game pass you can play all the yakuza
games which is dope which is super dope
to me because i've never played any of
them so if i want to jump into any of
them i can start from the very beginning
and work my way forward like that that
to me is like like super dope but i
think that this the the both of the
questions that you asked me in the very
beginning i think both of those things
are true i think this is like a trial
around
i think that if this works out well or
works up in their favor or even works
out halfway decently they're gonna
microsoft would acquire
what's sega i forget sega's parent
company i
literally blanked on it because i listen
i wrote it down earlier which i don't i
can't think of them um
sammy
stay there you go i almost said so i
almost said some move but yes
i think they i think they purchased
sammy all right man you gotta appreciate
you sammy i think
i if they do buy
sega i don't think they're buying sammy
sammy's a publicly traded company well
it's gonna be a lot harder to buy that
company but
sammy did separate its assets from sega
last year or the year before
so
you don't
so they could theoretically sell sega to
microsoft
because sammy owns sega i don't think
sega itself is a publicly owned company
i think sammy's a publicly owned company
that segason happens to own let's get
the this five dollar strip chat from
alvin
jason zander is the vi the vp of azure
if this had nothing to do with xbox
seems he would be doing it instead of
the vp of xbox it's literally his job
alvin if i had onto something emote on
the attic show which i probably should
bring some of those emotes over here
i'll probably do that for next week i
click that [ __ ] for you right now
because i agree with you i do think
there's a lot to say on what you're
saying uh i think that you know we'll
get into my opinion they're gonna let uh
hustle finish his opinion but then we
got a two dollar swoop shot from flame
uh play yakuza like a dragon hustle
perfection
like a dragon is a great game all right
so finish here finish your bars man
finish your bars
well i mean that was basically it um and
actually learned something new um shout
out to you adam for that super chat now
so i learned something new um
i look forward to seeing what comes out
of whatever is happening here because
i'm always looking forward to a new
experience but this does definitely
sound like something that's multiplayer
based something that's going to be
extremely community driven according to
what i just saw with that ign article
and i'm excited for the future whether
they by saying on that i don't really
they didn't really you know it'd be cool
if they did but um i i want to see
what's the new thing that they create
because always like the new stuff always
look like i love the merch i love my
retro stuff i love like the fact that
you can revive some stuff if they you
know acquire if they do acquire sake in
the long run i love the fact that you
can require revive a lot of stuff but i
do want to see what the new thing is i
want to see what the new thing is
i agree and and i think that
sega and microsoft you know they're good
fit that's why i've always felt like
microsoft
needs
that type of audience
sega's there just dandling
sammy has clearly cleared uh the
if if i haven't heard a company say buy
this damn company more than i've heard
sammy say buy sega i don't know what
else you don't separate your finances
from sega unless you're like
look man anyone
caught sell man hot stuff we'll give you
sonic for a cheeseburger at mcdonald's
like like well i just i just feel like
that there's something going on in the
back end uh you know i don't know if
it's something like buying sega it's
pretty big that's a pretty big thing to
say
and it's probably something small but i
do think that
it is worthy of looking at now when it
comes to
sega and microsoft's partnership in
general i think we're going to see
if anything
that's going to benefit gaming more than
anything it might not be the partnership
itself but the relationship over the
partnership being built
obviously
it's easy to tell a company like
sony when they hit them up for persona
5. yo
uh sega i want persona 5 exclusive to
playstation and when playstation
and sega have this good relationship and
sega and microsoft don't it seems to be
like yeah we don't need microsoft we'll
we'll let you buy the exclusive rights
to persona but then you have this type
of relationship with microsoft and sega
let's say persona 6 comes up let's say
playstation hits them back up me like
you know what persona 5 works so well
for us it worked great for us hustle you
know what we're going to do we're going
to give you this money let persona 6
come over to playstation exclusively you
know sega going to look they're going to
look at that money and they'll be like
yo that's a lot of money but they'll be
like
we're going to make microsoft piss if we
take this money
and now now there's more
there's more to lose
you know
if you've muddy the waters to take this
little bit of money which is not a load
it's a lot of money but if your money
the water's taking this money from from
sony to get persona 6 exclusively on
their platform you might
potentially damage this partnership
between sega and microsoft and i don't
think sega would take that bag because
at the end of the day i think that they
would value
microsoft's relationship with using
these type of cloud servers than they
would the money that sony would give
them to make persona 6 and exclusive
this goes for anything the yakuzas i
don't expect anything from sega being
exclusive ever again to anyone else
microsoft might get some exclusive [ __ ]
because of this because when you have
this kind of relationship with them look
at square enix and sony they had such a
great relationship such a good
partnership they even bought each other
stalks when they was in
in the gutter
because of this great relationship
they've built for the past 20 30 years
i'm probably exaggerating by 30. but
we're going to move on with that
they were able to get this type of
relationship to where when things are
looking south and they hit up square
enix and like yo final fantasy 7 remake
what do you guys want to make that
exclusive there was
a conversation to be had to make that
happen
and if they wouldn't have had that kind
of close relationship with square enix i
don't know if that kind of conversation
could have happened would you agree with
that kind of analogy
i agree and um i was gonna um say that
you know
sony in this case would be the short
money and microsoft in this case would
be the long money like yeah you know you
can get a million up front but
if you had the chance to make 10 million
over the course of lisa you can get a
million up front
over a year but if you can make three
million over a year like you you take
the you take the longer money even if it
may take a little bit longer to get to
you so you know i don't think that um i
think what we see now
are like the seeds
to plant the actual
different plant a little bit later on
along the line so it's just you know
right now it's just a it's a slow game
you know they're going steady at the
moment they're holding hands and then
you know well you're not the rest of it
though you take her out
you know what shout out to the shadow
puzzle
well what would be crazy
is that this spawns not exclusivity from
microsoft
but it spawns game pass from microsoft
where they can go out there and imagine
at e3 this year microsoft goes out there
and announces persona 6 on their stage
and at the end it says in game pass day
one
do you know how
first off
i'm gonna have to check on my
playstation brethren man i'm gonna have
to check on them
because
i thought
having
the show
on game pass affected some of them when
a lot of them didn't even play it it was
the concept of having the show in game
pass more than the game itself being in
game pass
but persona
a lot of these people play persona oh my
god please let it happen please let it
happen
i want
the fire in twitter like you know i know
that you know the spaces thing has been
causing a lot of friction on twitter
but man
persona 6 on xbox
doesn't have to be an exclusive but if
it's game pass and it's on xbox
oh man we're going to give some people
something to talk about today you guys
want your spaces come on let's give them
stuff to talk about
what do you want
in terms of the second
in terms of sega i mean because i do
like persona 5 i got 50 hours in
persona 5. um the vanilla version
i mean you know anything like i said i'm
getting what i want
the [ __ ] the first thing that i've
always wanted from like different
companies is always going to be
something new um you remember when sony
brought blue point i said with them i
hope they get to make their own thing
and we don't know his roommate that they
are going to make their own thing but i
don't want to divert from the
conversation they can make something new
but if they do give like persona 6 and
if it is in game pass
like you already know what's going to
hit because we know how atlas get down
we know the high atlas get down so
that's just going to be like uh i don't
want to say another notch in the belt
but like if you don't have game pass at
that point you love rpgs like it's bad
enough microsoft right now or xbox right
now got all the western rpgs pretty much
online and you know what they got fable
coming you know
now what
the name of it escapes me at the moment
no no well devout yes but it's uh
no no not that one it's a captain home
assumption the name escapes me at the
moment
simpson
yes did y'all had to run out no clue
what you guys are yeah i had a megan and
um there's the other gentleman who isn't
on twitter
out of worlds
you guys you got both the outer worlds
there and they got got all the dlc there
so there's a lot to be desired with with
all the western rpgs and if they get
sega random i mean they got the easton
rpgs oh look i mean that's your rpg box
because they you know xbox used to be
the shooter box as you know it's just
you know
it's like we've said on this podcast
before
um
when it comes to rpgs sure people love
the sony template people love that kind
of game
but if there's a good rpg that's almost
always getting game of the year almost
every single time remember out of worlds
2 out of worlds the original one that
was a very budgeted game very good
budgeted game but that was nominated for
game of the year
that was on that list
that was a budgeted
ip from obsidian a lot of people don't
realize it but stick of truth was made
by obsidian as well
great
stick of truth was made by obsidian uh
the second one was it but this the
original one was made by obsidian uh so
i i love that and that's why i love when
it comes to obsidian is that the amount
of diversity and types of rpgs they can
make obsidian can make any rpg they want
there's not a lot that they can't do in
the rpg field we got a five dollar super
chat from mr irishman do you guys see
xbox uh chyna twitter account tweeted
something about final fantasy 7 remake
last week then deleted the tweet no i
didn't catch that um
yo final fantasy 7 first off i want to
say that i don't know i might play i
might replay i haven't played it since
the original one did you play seven
remake
no sir no sir that's that i mean except
for seven pass
seven wasn't my thing um when when that
era of rpg came out i just i have moved
on to like i was playing sports games
grand theft auto at that point was just
running different stuff but i didn't
know as you know i didn't have a
playstation um
ilp episode 165. i pretty much use that
joint as a cd player i'm not gonna lie
but i think i'm gonna keep it true i'm
gonna keep it real but you hadn't been
on nintendo like like it originally was
supposed to be when nintendo was on abs
it had its own been on 64. i would have
ran it i would have ran it for sure
because like i was familiar with those
characters from final fantasy 3 which is
i think six over here and you know what
y'all can give me the dum dum dum
numbers over here but yeah this one's
gonna bump me off but i played i played
a bit of that though you know we could
talk a little bit about because we're
about to end the show probably give
another 15 minutes but
you know what i really
don't think people are really taking
into consideration
how good microsoft studios are doing
right now like look
sure a lot of them are making games for
multiple platforms you know you got age
of empires that's not on xbox i don't
want to necessarily think about the
console aspect i want to think about the
studios regardless what they're doing
you got psychonauts that was like a 96
97 i don't know i don't it was in the
90s there's a high 80s i meant high 80s
out of worlds
great game scored well
let me go ahead um what else halo's
about to come out now halo's obviously
up in the air we don't know
what
hey uh we don't know what halo is going
to do but what i really like what i'm
seeing is just
off these little bit of games we've seen
we've clearly seen that these studios
can deliver
it's just how much can they can deliver
you know i'm looking right now
uh the outer world's on ps4 is an 85.
the outer world is on xbox one's and 85.
so i mean you know you got really
successful ips
uh age of empire i think they're on four
aren't they
yeah
which i played a little bit of that
that's actually a really high quality
game 82
82 is a phenomenal score user score is a
77
no 76 so to me
like
we're make they're making good games
like you know we but attic though we
have a game that you completely forgot
about that you actually reviewed in
death blue definitely you know arcane i
believe made that so you gotta you know
you know we're gonna have to pay a
little bit credit and a little bit more
respect to uh microsoft
um forza the new falter comes out or i
think you'll be playing the adf 88 yep
this is what death would made
okay right so let me see you know 88
almost had that almost low 90s or
whatever which is still phenomenal
psychonauts 2 is a 91
really
okay
i
that hey
that's respect man
see this and that and you know obviously
we know
forza is going to do well
we know
halo is at least going to score 85 and
above
and if it scored below that i'd be very
shocked
so
all i'm saying is like look sony makes
really good games
but hustle
would you not be more inclined to go
somewhere where you get more consistent
good games and not just a couple big
bangers every couple years
i i've said i think
i can't remember where i was when i said
that i said but i would prefer like
10 games rated at an 85
than only three games
yeah and that
i've always used this this analogy i'll
let you speak in one second i apologize
um
when it comes to
how do you take on these highly
rated games you get 385 friends to go
beat the 92 up like
it's just like man what you gonna do
when you're being held by by forza
horizons 89 92
and then and then and then uh
uh psychonox 2 and it's 92 is just
just jabbing them over and over again
like
i just i have a lot of good faith in
these studios i feel like microsoft they
got a good pulse on the rpg market they
got a good pulse on the i mean they're
damn near the only racing market right
now
yes they got a good pulse on the rts
market they got a good pulse on the
third person actual the third person
market you know hellblade they got uh
gears of war because people forget gears
of war is in that vein
yeah they got it that means posts on
first person
with
oh yeah
halo doom oh my god yeah
yeah to me
they're so diverse it's unreal right now
it's just you got to make sure those
games come out and
right now
people think that it could go south and
i think it can too just depends on what
these games come out but we're seeing
them deliver and that's what i want to
point out we're seeing these games
deliver and that's all that matters at
the end of the day is how these games
deliver and everyone in the chat you
know that i'm uh being a hundred percent
real here if i felt like these games
weren't going to do well i'd have told
you i asked this but i honestly feel
like they're going to do well i think a
vow is going to score well fable's going
to score what oh i just i don't want my
i don't want my desks falling out man
they don't have jrpgs i'll give you that
but yeah i just i really
really optimistic about the future of
these consoles i do have one more
question for you how so do you have
anything more to talk about the studios
well in terms of the studios i mean the
the output is you know hopefully the
output stays high um you know i'm a halo
dude excuse me you know i'm a gays dude
um but i do want to i got we got to give
somebody that credit man that third
person over the shoulder sony template
view like listen you know you got a game
like god of war spider-man miles morales
for me uh astro bot or actual playroom
is another one
yeah i mean you know just certain things
like that so you know a lot of these
they are fighting for each other on
nintendo with metroid dread which i'm
gonna buy next
on the 25th i'm coming on 25th um you
know when we see stuff like that i just
like to see everybody compete and just
to make the best possible products so
like some of the heavy hitters are
coming out i'm with it i am excited i'm
more excited for xbox for the simple
fact that you know i love gays so i i
want to see that next one i want to see
the new stuff that um the coalition will
be working on man i'm just i'm looking
forward to it i'm looking forward with
the gamer and the greatest part about it
though is that even if i don't play them
all i got my pick for the ps5 stuff for
the xbox stuff for the nintendo stuff so
i got my pick up whatever i want to rock
man so i just look forward to the future
for all three of these councils i know
that's a you know diplomatic answer but
i'm not i'm not going to hold you i
can't lie about it
okay like okay so let look
let's let's move into this i do have one
thing i want to talk about real quick
because i do want to go over a little
bit uh because i usually try to have
this like an hour 25 minutes uh but
there is a couple things that do want to
run by because we haven't really talked
uh this week uh which i kind of want to
stream more so we have to talk about
that after this
privately so i see a lot of people
talking i got an argument with a couple
people and i want your opinion on this
it's gonna be a segment that we should
have it's gonna be called hustle my
buggin
okay look
i personally feel like you having
games from the playstation or xbox
regardless which one it is coming day
and date into that platform does devalue
the console maybe not the brand but the
console because if you don't need if you
lose
people on the console
to going to pc because they don't need
to buy the console i do feel like even
if it's just one that is devaluing the
console to those individual people sure
is there a lot of those people probably
not you know we got the kofis the the uh
the kofis the bgs uh these individuals
and the
they are very small demographic in the
gaming industry i don't think there's a
lot of them but i think those
individuals proves
that it does devalue the platform uh in
terms of a console not the brand because
if you don't need the console
then it devalues it by itself
okay
now this is where you talk yeah how am i
working hustle am i bugging yes
yes you are no okay yes yes you are yes
you are and i'll tell you why
my brother who wasn't here he's at work
i'm sure
he don't
he's apprehensive on getting in the pc
game man because although i got in the
pc gaming around 2016 or 2017 i forget
what year it was it must be 2017.
i think i had one issue with the game
and i know i granted thought of saying
andreas was one that wouldn't boot
through the rockstar launcher it works
fine now but it just didn't work well
then a lot of people
get consoles for convenience if god or
war ragnarok comes straight to pc it
don't it doesn't devalue anything
because everybody ain't going to
necessarily want to put up with the
hassle of pc gaming yeah when it works
it's great but when it don't work
it's like you're pulling your hair out
you're pulling you're pulling your beard
out whatever you got like you're going
crazy and you're trying to figure out
the things that should be fixed yes sir
all right so so hustle thinks i'm
bugging but i got it i got i got it i
got i got a i got to come back at it
okay so
obviously we just had you show up we
just had squid games show up on netflix
amazing things that really drove the
service you are still the number one
thing watched on netflix if i can get
you and i can get squid games on amazon
prime and hbo go or hbo whatever the
hell it's called these days hustle am i
going to be subscribed to netflix
you know why that's different how's that
different can i tell you what because
one of these things is with the click of
a button most of these things are absent
your television
yeah now if the amazon service comes in
at cheaper a little bit cheaper
then yeah we go over amazon if
what's that hulu
sells that thing for a little bit
cheaper you go with hulu you might put
up with a little bit more commercials
but you go with that so you'll find a
cheaper option at that point but the
reason why
that that's not really
an apt comparison is the fact that yo
addict you stick now granted you don't
got to spend 3 000 no pc like i did
i'm a crazy person you don't have to
spend that type of money on no pc
however however
right now if you buy a pc you might be
spending that much you might be spending
that much type of money you might be
spending that type of bread if you care
about the 4k visuals what your ps5 can
give you what your xbox series x can
give you if you care about the high
frame rate which both of those consoles
can give you and the xbox series s can
get you and you just want the
convenience you just get the console
it's right there you you know for the
most part when you boot that game up
it's not going to really crash you might
have a couple crashes day one but it
it's not too bad
pc on the other hand pc on the other
hand and you know this you might have to
google a fix for something when you buy
it and you don't know what's going on
you can literally have like a issue with
your ram and you don't know what's going
on it could be your graphics card could
be out of date
hell i mean i think in some cases your
grabbers probably could be too new and
before you i say oh how is that possible
yeah that that's been a thing to wear
like some newer cards
seem to work worse like i said anything
lower than like a 30 i think it's like a
30 60 i think audible was having trouble
i think playing whatever game he was
playing and i didn't have any problem i
got 28 ti i had no problem playing the
joint so
these these things are a lot of these
things are about a case-by-case basis
but no that's not the same man that's
not the same as netflix offering
something that is just as simple as a
click of a button yeah okay
and the reason i say it is is because
we're not talking we're not looking at
this aspect of like
a service we are but we aren't at the
same time i'm looking as from the aspect
as content
um there's a certain amount of content
on every platform that entices people to
go to that platform if you offer that
platform that that content on other
platforms then it comes down to what
platform does the best stuff
for instance if everything was on xbox
i'm pretty sure the majority people
would get an xbox because they have
gifting they have more features they
have a more of enticing service the only
thing they like is a lot of the better
games it's in the industry right now
such as last of us such as god of war
but if you put those on the best
platform that has everything else but
those games everyone's going to drift
towards an xbox because they have the
better services in general to this day
you still can't gift on playstation
they have a car system and no gifting
system makes no sense on playstation
that's why i i'm i'm in that that
mindset that's like look comes to
netflix
if i could get everything on netflix on
every other service it would come down
to what service has the better features
for me and i would leave netflix and go
to that service but i can't leave
netflix because they have the concept
that keeps me in that platform for
instance
sure there's a lot of people such as
your brother don't want to go to pc
there's a lot of people on pc they said
30
of uh
30 of people had a ps4 that had a pc
so it's 30 of people that's like 130
million people it's like 30 25 million
people that could potentially leave your
platform because they don't longer need
it now when you put it in aspects like
that that's it's a lot of people that's
a lot of people you got the bg's the
kofis the cavs got a lot of people that
have a playstation because they gotta
have a playset not because they want a
playstation so when you give these
people the out to leave they will leave
now keep in mind when they leave they're
leaving more than just not that buying
that console they're also leaving being
in that ecosystem they're not going to
go and get the call of duties on the
platform because that's where they want
to play because it's non-cheating
friends there etc etc they're not going
to have that option there they're going
to end up leaving that platform so
they're not going to be spending
microtransactions not going to be on
fortnight they're not going to be on war
zone so they're going to also lose money
in that form as well that's why i'm
saying that when it comes to devaluing
the platform it does devalue now and not
a lot because like i said earlier
the kofi's the bg's
me
in some way because i do have a okay
pool pc i got a 30-60 ti
so
we're probably going to buy the platform
anyway because we like newer stuff so
that's a very small percentage but i i
think it's
even if it's five percent of the gaming
community that would pull out of the ps5
because they can get it on the pc that's
still five percent of people that would
have bought a playstation i i do think
even that five percent leaving devalues
the platform maybe not the playstation
or the xbox platform but it devalues the
ps5 and the xbox series that's an x
i mean we i think we can agree to
disagree
i think you know moving i think moving
things on on pc from microsoft
in some strange ways helped it to be
honest with you i believe i really think
that it has helped the actual brand
itself but that's that's just my humble
thing i i got i got a super chat real
quick we gotta fight all the troops that
man with a plan i like that man with the
plan 69. what if xbox series x became a
pc now
uh pc games come to consoles uh a pc and
now pc games come to consoles so i don't
know if like you're referring to maybe
like they get a steam
uh a steam app on there they can you can
bring your steam library and they're
compatible with the xbox series x
so i'm kind of curious on what you meant
by that do you have any
concerns what he said on that if you can
get steam games on your xbox series x
nah i mean if if it would be that would
be cool if if i didn't have like a pc if
i didn't have two pcs i got two capable
pcs to play games on so for me that
that's not gonna matter um that will be
beneficial to anybody and everybody who
doesn't game on pc who has an xbox or
playstation if they were to do that that
that would be more beneficial to them i
mean it wouldn't
like none of that stuff bothers me like
i know we was talking before we uh got
started i want to play the awful escape
like on pc so it doesn't really nothing
that really bothers me none of that is
none of that would change well let's put
it this way none of that would change
anything for me and again um it needs to
be said you know i know you said i know
i said i disagree with you on if things
devalue the platform and that i go with
the games that man i i definitely will
go over the games all but
but for me i think that's for everyone
she goes where the games are at i agree
with you and even in terms of pc for me
in particular the reason why i chose to
jump out there with pcs because i
started to get to know you guys in the
community guys and girls in the
community and if i ever had a question i
could lean on one of you all for help
but honestly it's for performance like i
don't have it in front of me now but i
used to have a
21x9 1440p monitor like when god of war
comes to that now i want to take a shot
of playstation but anything like when
anything comes to that that supports
that resolution i'm back on it man
both of my cards can actually run that
uh my 1660 that i got in in this
streaming rig can run it by 2080t i can
definitely run it so i look forward to
like that but i look forward to it in
terms of performance because i want to
go over 120 um 20 hertz a second i mean
you know but that's it and shout out to
our clients dudes will finally uh got
y'all a taste of uh you know over 100
frames like shout out to y'all man
because it's a wonderful thing
all right so we're we're going to end
this we're going in this on a fun way
hustle all right because apparently i'm
bugging but we're going to move on i'm
really going to keep i'm really going to
keep doing that though i i really am
because i like that that's a nice little
back and forth what's your plans for the
holiday in terms of gaming what is your
most
anticipated game that you want to play
this holiday
my mom will say the next we'll say the
next six months let's take away the
holiday the next six months
well i'm gonna put halo infinite there
because i look forward to playing
excited a lot of fun in the beta
the last of us on pc god i know i'm not
right uh relax and i got the last of us
for or excuse me that's the last of us
uncharted until i lost like it's the
lost legacy collection i look forward to
playing that on my pc um in terms of the
retro stuff
we spoke before we went live earlier i
ordered the wrong tetris i wanted tetris
too as opposed to tetris attack um i'm
getting back in my retro bag so i'm
looking forward to playing those over
you just match a block in another block
and you put it on and it breaks them all
and then you match another block i got
the same thing on my phone
all tetris is the same
nah but i look forward to playing that
um i got turtles and time in the back so
i definitely look forward to playing
that and um nba streets is right here so
i i kind of i'm going to be jumping all
over the place but as far as the
multiplayer stuff is concerned
there's some behave
and it's interesting that it's
interesting that you're
you're really looking forward to that
because
the reason i think that's interesting
is because you're not necessarily a halo
guy
nope so that is all the community and
the beta has won you over to a point
and
i feel like that's going to happen a lot
like you know i do think i want to do
because i do have a show it's called
attic spotlight uh i don't do it a whole
lot i only do it on certain games i
think i'm going to do a halo addict's
halo infinite attic spotlight before the
game comes out
um
i don't know when we might replace an
attic show one week for it
uh and get a panel together for that
uh four
halo infinite but you know i'm excited
for
uh for dying light two
i don't know why
but dining light 2 looks really
appealing to me and i really want to try
it and i i feel like a lot the original
dying light didn't get the flowers i
felt like it deserved and i feel like
that they can really
win that crowd back over now but you
know that's just my opinion and i
actually want to play this pokemon game
too
uh i'm gonna i'm gonna play that because
uh
that's pearl diamond i believe uh shiny
pearl whatever the hell they call them
i'm gonna play that man i'm probably
gonna play some online you know see see
how some of these people in this chat uh
because people keep thinking that i suck
at these online pokemon games all right
when i stick
a blastoise up your ass you ain't gonna
be thinking i suck anymore but i
appreciate everyone coming through man
hustle what do you got going on man tell
me tell me what's up tell me what hustle
is doing this week
right now this week i will be
not putting up content because you know
just different little situations here
and there however however however i have
something on the way called a super nt
you don't get an unboxing or some type
of overview of that super nt for those
of you all who do not know um i'm in the
super i'm in the super nintendo games in
particular that's my favorite game of
all time
but it's my favorite console of all time
rather i got super mario all-stars i got
turtles in town i got the wrong tetris
tetris 2 as opposed to tetris attack i
got a lot of stuff on the way and oh i
got aladdin on the way to uh addict i
don't know if you ever played aladdin on
super nintendo i thought you fired boy i
think fire so i'll be getting into that
for the you know for like pretty much
this month and i'm getting in the next
i'm really waiting on halo um
there's nothing else that i really want
to finish up i said i was gonna play the
artful escape i'm gonna run today at two
hopes that's four hours so i should i
should definitely finish that by the
time we meet back up next week
um no but i'm i'm in the retro bag right
now as you know what's up eddie carrie
also you going to play are you going to
play forza
yeah that's um the fifth no that's the
fifth for you um i think it's the 11th
that comes out
yeah um okay i think i don't know if the
game pass one is the early one or not
but i don't have to look into that
yeah oh no no well let's put it this way
if it's available on the fifth i'm
running i'm running i just hope they
don't make you know what they did the
last time it might be the ultimate that
lets you do it
i
they remember they had that weird ass
the weird-ass graphic chart that that
was shown when
uh when everything came out i don't
uh chat you guys know
i was confused game pass ultimate get
the game early or is it just
the
ninth on uh or early access okay so yeah
so november 9th from what i'm saying in
the chat thank you guys so i'll i'll be
doing that november 9th
november you like it i think you'll like
it man i think you'll like it oh no i
don't get it twisted i like i i love
halo horizon i don't like the the sim
bass joint but i like the um i like the
the one where you can write race with
your friends and it's just all over the
place how you gonna race against the
the
whatever that was i like i like that as
opposed to like the the other as opposed
to the sim i like the more arcady one
so
uh the ninth is when the game comes out
right
that is
that's next tuesday
all right that's that's that's the uh
the podcast we might have to to to do
the podcast at six next week to give you
a little bit more time to play it i
don't know we'll see or just do the
podcast next week on a wednesday because
i do want to talk to you about it all
right but you know i appreciate everyone
for coming through man you know uh i i
actually mad tired but i ha
the the podcast energized me like a damn
energizer bunny everyone hit that like
button in that chat man get that above
100 before i exit out of this man if we
we are 13 away if you guys want me to
play these lame ass old ass games you're
gonna have to get that over a hundred
likes or i ain't doing nothing but i
appreciate everyone for coming through
make them play tetris y'all no we ain't
playing tetris i'd rather pull my eyes
out but i definitely appreciate it for
coming through man we'll see you next
week and until next time i'm bug